malika belarbi et aides soignantes
depuis 25 ans dans le centre de long
séjour d abondance
comme la plupart du personnel c'est au
début de la crise qu'elle a découvert
effaré que la france ne disposait pas du
stock de protection nécessaires pour
faire face à l'épidémie manqué de masque
pendant le début du gris au niveau du
confinement
pratiquement tous les soignants des
ehpad n'avait pas de maths parce qu'on a
pensé que c'était inutile au niveau
matériel au niveau du savon
hydroalcoolique certains établissements
n'avaient y en a qui en avait pas il n'y
avait pas aussi une absence de gand
alors je vous dis pas des sourds blues
il y en a aujourd'hui jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en a pas et on a très peu
les établissements sont complètement là
ils sont un peu tout sans stress parce
qu'ils sont au niveau tendue au niveau
du matériel sequedin d'ici la fin la
semaine prochaine en aura plus rien ce
qui la révolte avant tout c'est le
manque d'anticipation des autorités
sanitaires
mon reproche c'est au niveau d'aidé du
gouvernement qui n'a pas pris à temps
la commande n'a pas pris en temps le
le problème sur locaux vie 19 et qui met
aujourd'hui nos établissements en
difficulté parce que les mesures elles
ont pas été prises en amont et le virus
circule aujourd'hui elle s'inquiète pour
cette population vulnérable dont elle
est en charge
nous avons des cas l'intérieur de kovy
19 qui nous inquiète parce
qu'aujourd'hui les personnes âgées qui
sont des personnes vulnérables avec des
polypathologies pour
il y aura malheureusement beaucoup de
décès moi je le souhaite pas mais je
pense qu'une part sur cette route là une
inquiétude que partage ludovic milice
dont la mère est dans un établissement
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
justement la maison de retraite les
clairement qu'il ya trop de personnages
et qui peuvent donc de passer des plaies
tatum ou quoi et le consort trouve ça un
peu comme la france on est un des pays
les plus puissants au monde alors que
l'épidémie n'a pas encore atteint son
pic
le personnel soignant poursuit ses
efforts entre peur et sens du devoir
ils réclament une action rapide des
autorités face à ce qui se profile comme
une véritable catastrophe sanitaire et
humaine